my name is Joanna Valencia I'm 28 years
old I live in the Divino Nino
neighborhood in the south of Bogota
I arrived with my three kids four years
ago displaced by the violence in the
choco region and since the first day we
never had access to water for a
household course personal hygiene
cleaning it's very complicated
parts of the neighborhood receive water
late at night at times every three or
four days I depend on the good heart of
neighbors that share some of their water
with me
I'm working as a security guard there
are days that I don't bring any food at
work because I have no water to cook it
uniform is dirty because I haven't been
able to wash it same with my kids school
uniform their shoes I have loads of
dirty dishes because I haven't been able
to wash them either
I hope to be able to buy a big tank or
find an organization that could help us
get one
given that this country is so rich in
water it's kind of illogic that we are
living in a neighborhood where access to
water is the main issue
I think we have a right to water because
water is life
foreign
[Music]